what role was it or what was it that
made everyone kind of open their eyes
and go
our little katie she's got something
here i don't know she's really doing it
honestly was it a guest star on
something was it midnight mass like
that's how i was taking midnight mass
was like the 30th thing you've done
i don't know but like even after hill
house they were like oh that's fun she
does these little horror things
and it wasn't until midnight mass that i
started hearing from my mom's friends
and my mom where they're like you're
actually a remarkable actress what about
hush
no
nothing from hush
they thought it was good but like it
wasn't like katie has a thing going it
was like how cute can you still be in
katie she'll be back soon
wow because when i watched that i was
like oh who's this
who's this she's playing a uh a deaf
writer
or do you say hearing impaired what am i
supposed to say
i could say deaf deaf community deaf is
a good thing to be okay good good i like
that but um
all right so you do all these things
you're in la you got a casting director
who's kind of like what was her name
again
lindsay chad she kind of hooked you up
with reps and you started to get right
you got representation from there yes
and that was a big thing for you and
then you started going out on auditions
and having auditions for the first time
yes
yes and what was the first big thing you
can remember getting that was like
i'm gonna make some money i'm gonna pay
my bills oh i booked um i booked an
indie film called steam
called stevie
steam steam steamroller
right
how was it working with ali sheedy
amazing she was amazing you weren't star
struck at all
um a little bit but she isn't such a
human like you know
it takes about
what's like when you meet celebrities
how long do you think it takes like
maybe
an hour or so before they start just
being a person how long for you it just
depends i mean there's been some that i
just like you know i've worked with
stallone and i'm like hanging with him
on set and i'm laughing with him and
he's he knows me by name and we're
talking and we're like you know we're
sitting down at lunch and we're like you
know it's weeks i've worked with them
i'm still like everyone so i'm like
that's sylvester stallone
[Music]
you're working with him now
he's an usher he is and that's not a
secret
no no no no he's been announced
wow
did you get your star wars uh poster
sign or did mike ask him for an
autograph yet not yet we'll get there
but like it's still like wow and he's
wonderful
talented humble kind generous everything
you want your heroes to be and a big
part she has a big part
wow mark hamill